the first trailer for black adam is
finally here showcasing shazam's
longtime nemesis and his impressive
powers but who are all those other meta
humans dc comics fans know what's up but
if you're new to the world of black adam
keep watching for answers
since the justice society of america or
jsa is clearly going to be a key part of
black adam's story in what looks like
the present day the trailer highlights a
few members of the team and their flashy
abilities one of the biggest reveals is
adam smasher who's played by none other
than to all the boys i've loved before
star noah centeno although we can't
really see his face behind that mask
adam smasher does his best dr manhattan
impression by striding through the
streets at his giant size it's an
impressive shot that reveals a good look
at adam smasher's costume complete with
glowing blue highlights across his body
in the comics adam smasher's real name
is albert rothstein and he's a
meta-human with the powers to increase
his size and strength but the glowing
blue highlights on his suit in the black
atom trailer might suggest that he's
using technology to enhance his size
rather than relying on meta-human
abilities it'll be interesting to see
whether adam smasher has a rivalry with
black adam like he does when the ruler
of kondak joins the team in 2001's jsa
number 21. the trailer also shows off
aldous hodge as carter hall aka hawkman
and it's great to see him finally get
the cinematic treatment he even gets a
great line in the trailer telling black
adam that heroes don't kill people
well i do dc fans might remember that a
version of the winged archaeologist
shows up on the smallville series where
he's played by michael shanks foul
kinchel also had a more recent crack as
the character in the flash and dc's
legends of tomorrow so it's about time
that carter is finally making the leap
to the big screen the footage shows him
wearing a regal suit of red and gold
armor before he extends his wings which
dc fans know are made out of the
precious inf metal carter hall is the
reincarnated version of an ancient
egyptian prince khufu and he's always
destined to die at the hands of his arch
enemy hathset so don't be surprised if
hawkman dies in black adam only to show
up in a future movie under a different
identity that's kind of his deal what a
fitting fate
it's also worth pointing out that his
story is intertwined with the story of
hawkgirl who is the reincarnated version
of princess cheyara it's possible that
she'll also play a part of the dc
extended universe somewhere down the
line
included in the trailer's short jsa
introductions is a small clip of what
looks like a cloud of green gas
rocketing through the sky this is most
likely the superhero cyclone set to be
played in black atom by quintessa
swindell in the comics cyclone whose
real name is maxine huncle is the
granddaughter of abigail ma huncle the
original red tornado though her
grandmother may not have had any
inherent superhero powers outside of a
skill for hand-to-hand combat maxine has
developed an incredibly powerful set of
abilities much more akin to later
iterations of the red tornado cyclone
has the power to manipulate wind which
allows her to create and control
phenomena such as tornadoes whirlwinds
and cyclones though it's incredibly hard
to get a glimpse of what is at the
center of this gaseous anomaly in the
trailer the green and red color scheme
matches up perfectly with the red hair
and green suit that cyclone wears in the
comics
near the end of the trailer we watch as
black adam stops a van driven by
professor adriana tomas and her
associate as the two are crossing
through a war-torn desert on the side of
this van is the name sharuda electronics
which ought to sound very familiar to
long time fans of dc comics
in the comics sharota is the name of the
capital city of kondak a sovereign
nation located on the sinai peninsula
that was conquered by none other than
black adam himself
the city is even named after adam's
first wife sheruda who died thousands of
years ago in ancient egypt since we know
that adam is at least at the start of
the film only recently released from his
5 000 years of imprisonment it seems
unlikely that we will see him take
control of sharuda and kondak though the
appearance of sharona electronics might
indicate that the capable city will play
a key role in the story itself one has
to wonder how adam will react knowing it
was named after his long-dead wife
it seems that black adam will explore
the long-standing relationship between
the titular anti-hero and adriana tomas
aka isis an egyptian goddess imbued with
powers upon her acquisition of a
mystical amulet unfortunately the
trailer makes it clear that the
characters aren't destined for a happy
reunion as she looks nervous to see him
as he parades around the desert grabbing
rockets with his bare hands such is a
day in the life of black adam did he
just catch a rocket
of course it remains to be seen how
tomas played by sarah shahi will inform
black adam in the movie in the comics
she can be credited for helping him
discover his inner good and uncover his
romantic side she basically changes his
world view after he frees her from
enslavement at the hands of the
villainous intergang organization black
adam looks set to explore the titular
character putting the anti an anti-hero
so it's safe to assume that isis will
play a big part in his journey
considering the fact that black adam has
seemingly been down for the count for 5
000 years at the outset of this film
it's interesting to note that the heroes
waiting to greet him are from a
different era themselves at least in the
comics while their group's name isn't
mentioned in the trailer the jsa
originated in the 1940s during the
golden age of comic books dr fate and
hawkman played in the film by pierce
brosnan and aldous hodge were original
members along with familiar names like
the flash
the team was eventually phased out in
1951 and replaced by the justice league
of america in 1960 seen as a super team
of yesteryear they've undergone a number
of revivals with adam smasher and
cyclone joining the official ranks of
the jsa in 2011. it's notable then that
the trailer places the bulk of the
film's plot in the present day or
something close rather than harkening
back to the 40s or 50s
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
black adam are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]